pull out the wristbands and let's
actually go through it this time and
just tell us about what they are what
they mean
so uh jorge's got a bunch of these
wristbands these are human smugglers put
these on on people like why don't you at
least keep these two because it's good
yeah that's kind of scary it's kind of
creepy yeah so these are the
so this is what um
kind of our reporting has showed is that
the central americans have to pay a
human smuggling group or cartel group to
cross uh the rio grande river and the
different color wristbands means there's
different human smuggling groups so here
we have red ones we have some black ones
and we have some purple ones the
majority of these ones say entregas
which means delivered that means the
product has already been delivered so
either if they haven't paid the full
payment then they become indentured
servants on our side but they also have
to pay for the kids yeah these are it's
insane to to see it in person because i
mean literally like pull it straight so
people can read what it says yeah like i
mean like like literally literally last
night guys we were interviewing migrants
coming from nicaragua our human smoker
right in front of us we have the video
it's up on twitter and um we got to
collect these from the mic the reason
that i keep getting asked like why do
you collect them it's like we're trying
to show these are numbered dude these
are serial numbers yeah and it's
different like it's different you know
for me just telling you like hey this is
what's going on and then when you see it
in person you're like whoa wait dude
this is this is a mechanized industry
there is a serial number on these bands
well well organized four thousand one
hundred eighty six yeah four four eight
and ian and then like like last night
like the little kids would have them on
their on like their goals
and
it's just it's crazy how they treat
these people like i said last night
there was a moment where one of the the
males from nicaragua had his little boy
and you could just tell
he was not the father i mean he was
manhandling this kid like a product and
when we when we had the cameras filming
him he was frank frantic trying to
trying to like hide behind a national
guardsman and the crazy thing to tim is
being there in person is so you know on
the mexican side we're witnessing the
wrath come with the with the kids i mean
we're talking about babies in these
boats that could drown i mean it's like
one of the saddest things when they get
dropped off on the american side and
seeing that struggle but
so what they they come from the mexican
side on the american side is a national
guard with flashlights directing them to
come here so then they'll literally drop
them off right in front of the national
guard sometimes the national guard goes
and assists them and then so we ask them
like you know how come you guys don't
pursue the human smugglers according to
them they say they don't arrest the
human smugglers because their worry is
that when they go to arrest them that
they'll flip over the raft so then the
kids will drown and all the attention
goes to the kids
but
i just can't believe this like it's just
happened so brazen yeah
so so it doesn't even matter we could
have every single national guard from
every single state be there
but if they're literally doing nothing i
mean and then they have like m16s they
don't even have they're not even loaded
dude migration has been the downfall of
a lot of nations over the over the years
look at look at sweden right now they're
they're struggling massively with having
all these this huge influx of that
that's i actually don't think that's
true uh a lot of the problems that
sweden's facing has to do with 20 years
ago
so
somali somali refugees and it's not even
the refugees it's their kids who are who
are because sweden is so overwhelmingly
racist
what they did was in the 90s they
brought in a bunch of somali refugees
those refugees then had children who are
100 somali but born in sweden speaking
swedish and then because swedes are so
racist they were like we're not going to
give you jobs or education so you
basically created this you create
ghettos and then these people who are
from sweden
aren't viewed as somali by their you
know family in somalia and they're not
viewed as swedish by people in sweden so
they form pocket communities effectively
viewing themselves outside the state so
that's that's sweden's sweden's issue
and i i you know of all the people to to
talk about social justice or whatever
now sweden's legit racist like
they will not give you a job if you do
not conform and we we talked to a bunch
of americans who said the same thing so
it's maybe rice isn't the right word
right where maybe they're they're like
um homogenous like nationalists yeah
like if you are not discernibly swedish
in accent and color they won't hire you
it becomes very very difficult but they
will create ghetto subsidized housing i
mean like literal ghetto not you know
subsidized housing blocks where they'll
put you and then be terrified when
violence breaks out so so it is it is a
bit different you know in sweden yeah
going back to the the roman empire
basically part of the downfall of that
was all the mass migration from the
north because the huns were coming from
the east and it's just
you know just spilled over and then
you'd see in desperate times there would
be these huge like
like civilizations would be migrating
and the romans would go murder them all
because they couldn't they couldn't
handle it it was like if they come we
lose so they would so like this is the a
horrible dystopic future that could
happen if we don't
somehow solve this yo it's happened it's
it's happened well we have technology we
have like long-range communication 1.4
1.5 million apprehensions this year not
counting the people who
break through without being caught
this it's unprecedented this is
you know people are you know people say
i'm doomer i'm black filled we shouldn't
be we're going to win i'm like you
didn't understand something
we freedom may win
but not before the system around us
falls apart
so where you are things might actually
start getting i mean it's bad right now
right but i don't think the united
states survives everything that's
happening from the mandates from the
from the the breakdown between states
the social cohesion to the mass
migration
it's just i don't see the republic as it
stands surviving this now as for us as
individuals and our culture i think it's
going to be a good for a lot like texas
is going to do better florida will do
better west virginia will do better new
hampshire will do better new york and
california i suspect we'll do worse but
maybe those people will enjoy it and
they'll be happy with it tim did you see
uh sarah silverman come out and was like
oh we need to split split it to like usa
one in usa too that sounds like a great
idea yeah yeah yeah
it's okay it's not about we need to it's
that the sentiment is there and i think
we're on that track no matter what we
want to do
because we have two different
populations in america it's we have the
i listen to everything that government
tells me and then we have the hey stay
stay out of our lives we still want to
keep that old school american style so
we're seeing um that split but what's
actually also interesting on the
immigration is uh chile this past week
was actually holding protests against
the venezuelan migrants that are coming
into their country so we're seeing kind
of that kind of play out in in south
america as well but as of right now
we're getting reports that more haitians
are making the trek to the u.s mexican
border yeah
and uh well it was fun huh yeah
that's a black belt soviets only yeah
yeah that's a black panthers while he's
holding a literal black pill
yeah it's uh it's ian's obsidian
sophie you only asked 69 years the
united states we got you know 200 and
about 270 almost 260 something right is
that where we're at
yeah and just letting in this huge
migration isn't good i mean and then
we're also seeing with all the um kind
of the afghan immigrants that we just we
just brought in the refugees we just
brought in there was those are there
already reports of some sexual assault
in some of the military camps that
they're staying at
we just have to vet these people i was
speaking to border patrol agents they're
saying it's impossible to vet
these markers at the at the pace that
they are they say it takes such a long
time they're like there's no way we know
anything about these people especially
the guidaways that's actually the the
real scary number when you when you tell
look so there's a lot of stuff we talk
about when we say like the republic is
falling or whatever joe biden's rule by
decree separation of powers are are
completely gone the states
are so far at odds with each other
there's there's no there's no um
compromise the democrats are like get
rid of the filibuster and ram through
our agenda in the face of republicans
instead of just take care of your own
states why should new york ramp through
an agenda for west virginia it makes no
sense but what are we hearing in
response in response conservatives being
like if we get the house back we're
going to impeach biden and you know i
respect that they should but they're
like you know we'll get rid of the
filibuster then we'll ram through stuff
and it's like bro the only track we're
on is it breaks apart but when you
mention the national guard is just
fanning these people in and being like
well there's not much we can do it's
like dude when your border can't guard
its border and people can walk back and
forth for takeout you have no border and
if you have no border you have no
country it's it's honestly it's it's a
joke to have these how you know just
watching like them go back and forth
then you know seeing the national guard
and like what are we doing to it and
there's like literally no no enforcement
and the cartels continue to win the
establishment politicians that
push these policies
continue to win and i just don't know
how how long we could sustain this i
think we're on pace right now for
two um like two million apprehensions at
the u.s southern border still not
counting uh those those got aways that
get in we have these large family units
that we don't know if they're family
units getting processed into united
states getting flown all over the
country i just flew to today
from uh from the mcallen airport to
dallas and in on my flight
i mean it was the majority was central
american migrants
holding with the folders that say i
don't speak any english can you help me
with my next flight and and then and
then on the other side it has all the um
all the like where they're stopping so
say like mcallen to houston to new york
or mcallen houston to new jersey
whatever so they're being flown all over
so are the haitians like i said the
majority haitians that i interviewed are
going to florida but still they're
they're getting flown all over and
there's no track um there's no way to
track these migrants and another thing
is there's no way to make sure that they
even go to that core order i was
speaking of border patrol sources i say
only 13 of the time they even go to that
to that court order so it's they they
already said we are essentially just
already let them loose and then when you
speak to the he's like hey are you gonna
go to your co-order they're like
what
i live here now
so they look at me like i'm like i'm
crazy though so that's the that's the
situation that uh we have a hand and
supposedly we're still going through a
pandemic yet we're releasing thousands
of folks uh we're not tested for
copenhagen
who was it uh peter ducey is that his
name mm-hmm the journalist yeah
yeah yeah he asks uh saki
are you testing these people for covet
when they cross the border and she's
like no yeah she's like she's like oh
we're not testing because they don't
plan to stay here long i'm like well
that's like a tourist yeah i'm like
that's the opposite we're seeing on the
ground the thing is when they get a
court order these migrants that court
order could take up to even three years
for eve for them even to have a date
what is the red bracelet
these are just like i said yeah it's
like every every color is a different
migraine or smuggling group so last last
night we were running into the same
group with with all these uh with all
these black black bracelets and the
majority of the migrants that we spoke
to last night were coming from nicaragua
we did meet two from cuba which i was
pretty pretty shocked but
every time that we're down there we want
to show these people that or show the
american audience like look what's going
on at an alarming rate and the thing is
it's like the national attention from
the border it like the spotlight moved
as soon as the haitians got cleared out
of the bridge we were there all the
mainstream media left and they were done
and i was like you know what let's let's
continue to to show people what you know
what's going on and i'll be back i'll be
back in texas pretty soon but
it the the this situation like i said it
rolls out not just you know texas but
like how you know sonic and i'm being in
california seeing those migrants being
forced to work to those grow ups and
it's happening all all across california
in different states as well you what
you were saying in like in ancient rome
they were dealing with a migration
crisis yeah the huns came from the east
and and tons of civilizations fled into
like northeast rome is that basically
the fall of the empire's big part of it
there was also i wasn't there like a
credit crunch
um i don't know i know in greece there
was i don't know if any ancient rome
there was it does feel though like china
is laughing at us seeing this huge
demise and
kind of everything you were saying to
tim with like the state powers and stuff
but it's also that our elites in this
country are not even loyal to this
country they have already aligned
themselves with with china whether it's
big business whether it's entertainers
or politicians they've all decided that
they've aligned themselves with
you know the chinese maybe 2008 was the
iceberg
and since then the elites have been like
well we got 20 years
start collecting that silverware to sell
off and they hit up china and say look
our ship's sinking we want a place you
want we want a safe landing so we'll
give you all the good fine china from
the boat
that's what we're facing look at uh the
whole situation with uh with a john cena
you know he came out and said something
about positive or i think he like
recognized taiwan and then within two
days he's already making his video in
mandarin apologizing to the chinese
people but that's so that's that's all
the american companies do the same thing
is they they'll bow down their head to
china that's why um that's why i love
south park when they continue to troll
china and
and jing and stuff like that but yeah i
mean like i said our elites our
politicians have all aligned uh with
with them and you know they're not loyal
to this country i mean we've already
been seeing this you know in the nafta
and the trade deals when we shipped all
of our uh manufacturing jobs to china
and you know we saw states like michigan
and ohio penn state i mean pennsylvania
lose all that manufacturing jobs and we
saw all those basically you know huge
unemployment and men that you know we're
used to i'm talking about like single
income family men now have no have no
jobs because admit the those
manufacturing jobs got shipped either
now we're seeing on the southern border
all the fentanyl and opioids getting
pushed into those same communities
it's a bit apocalyptic i guess
i think in the long run i mean humanity
is going to be fine
but for a lot of people i think they
view america as the world
and so what i see it is like you know
look
if in the end west virginia texas new
hampshire florida wyoming whatever red
state says we're gonna do our own thing
is that really the end of the world is
it really
bad i don't know no definitely not
look at the sea people is another group
of migrants 1200 bc or something that
came from the north and no one knows why
but they overran mesopotamia it was the
end of like civilization as it was known
and then like small dark age and then
you start to see like the resurgence but
that's just the nature of reality is is
tragedy and migration
i don't know we have great technology
you know long-range electricity well
long-range communication electricity so
maybe maybe we can use the american
ideals and rewrite like a a more
organized system for the globe i think
it's beyond nationalism at this point
obviously these borders don't really
matter anymore but it's also like a huge
it's a huge cultural problem because
these people are not going to assimilate
and if they're working
low you know low-wage low-skill jobs
they're most likely going to get on some
type of welfare that then after that the
american taxpayer has to pick up that
bill not only that like let's say if
someone's whole ideology is not aligned
towards you know protecting my
protecting what america is based on and
stuff like that and like they go towards
empathizing more with these migrants so
like think about
like i would appeal to them like think
about what they have to go through right
because like when we were talking to all
these people
in the deserts they were like we watch
these people run these marijuana camps
all these illegal immigrants they do not
look happy they have to work in like 100
degrees out in the open running these
platforms being forced to do so if they
don't abide by these rules they get
killed carter will kill them so if
you're like just like as like let's say
you're like a full-on progressive and
you're all about immigration and all
about letting people in like just think
about what conditions these people have
to go through but the fact that sonic
they don't because this is impacting
black and brown people at a record
number and they're nowhere to be found
not not one progressive has even came
down to the border and said look at
these conditions look at these uh
facilities that are that are over
populated by over 500 percent some of
these like i said some of these paws
are only made for eight people they got
400 people in there even nbc news is
reporting that they're getting sexually
assaulted where is that outrage
only when they need votes they'll come
they'll come speak up but that's it yeah
otherwise it's a conspiracy like look at
the photos and like they came from like
the haiti situation like those photos
were like horrible
like if like let's say you have like no
empathy whatsoever to like like the
american ideal and protecting populism
and all that stuff like just empathize
with these people
like this whole situation at the end of
the day was created by
these policies and these attracted these
people and they were like all star yeah
and let's say a little exploit if like
let's take advantage of it and now
they're going through this whole mess
like as a super progressive person like
i'm pretty sure this is not what you
wanted to see all these people like go
through all this mess yeah i'm
interested now in the the 2024 race
because immigration is going to become
again a top issue a lot of democratic
voters that i'm speaking to every day
the immigration issue is getting them to
switch they said okay hold on and that's
why biden's approval rating just kept
dipping and then we were speaking to
some dha sources who they told us the
body administration was taking such a
political blow back on the haitian
migration they said by friday those
those all those haitian migrants need to
be off the bridge and port of entry open
we're going to act like nothing ever
happened but i don't think democrats can
survive politically
no this is a huge blow back i mean you
got a year basically an eternity so
we'll see what happens but biden's
approval ratings in the gutter the
honeymoon period's over people are
starting to wake up to the fact that
this guy's out of his gourd he can't run
or manage anything
i think joe biden's presidency was
literally a
steal all the silverware before
the people find out what your your plan
is so it's like south park remember that
south park episode from 2000 i think it
was 2008. obama and mccain run for a
president and the real the real point
was it was a heist
they they needed to get access to the
white house so it was like uh it was
like ocean's eleven or whatever yeah it
was like through childhood whoa that's
what it is joe biden was like i'll get
pr once i become president i can extract
as much as i can from the system before
it implodes and uh kamala harris has
also taken a huge hit on her popularity
because she basically got assigned borzo
and she's been taking a hit and
according to like like the some of these
white house sources who have came out
and are talking they're saying come on
here doesn't want to visit the board
because she doesn't even want to take
the blame anymore and she kind of felt
like they put her in that position but
she's she's taken a huge hit biden has
taken a huge hit because on this one
issue you could get those latino
democratic voters to say hold on this is
our people now
i'm not voting for this again so we'll
see then all those um you know and the
data backs it up because if you look at
the texas border towns they're all 80
majority latino in 2016 all those border
towns voted overwhelmingly for clinton i
mean they're democrat even 2020 trump
won all those counties by the border and
if you're seeing those uh working-class
latinos finally say this is enough is
enough it's impacting our local
communities i just entered i put up the
video on twitter where i interviewed
latino working class in del rio and they
were just livid at the haitian migration
situation i mean that was funny i was
speaking to one resident whose brother
is a veteran he said that when his
brother needed to go to the hospital
they were full of migrants they could
not help them out next year is gonna
shock i i think it's it's fair to say if
if the trends continue with the border
of texas or with miami a blue district
going red
i mean democrats might
be shocked historically
a president doing this bad should lose
30 to 50 seats the border wasn't even
this bad under obama i mean and the
thing is when we were coming the border
crisis in the beginning i kept thinking
oh it can't get worse than this you then
it the numbers continue to get worse
like i said july and august first
back-to-back months over 200 000
apprehensions we're already over 1
million if i think by the same rate last
year we're already at a 5 increase i
mean 500 increase in apprehensions this
is
nothing like we've ever seen before i
speak to border patrol they're
overwhelmed and now they're also they
also not only are they overwhelmed with
the situation they're not getting any
help from the administration and then to
top it off they're now being attacked
politically by that administration with
these
fake viral photos of them getting
whipped and what i love about that story
is the photographer for that uh two days
ago told el paso ktsm which is you know
local news station that him and his
colleagues didn't see any whipping at
all yet the administration ran with it
uh gensake came out and announced that
the buying administration is going to
ban horse patrol in the del rio sector
and those agents that day are put on
leave
all eyes
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time